one of the greatest discoveries into a
first-century is crisper gas 9 which
allows scientists to cut and manipulate
our genomic material so take your
scalpel try to cut the DNA and replace
it with your DNA of interest no it
doesn't sound so simple
and it doesn't work this way just joking
but in this video I'll be talking about
how CRISPR is done and how scientists
even figure out that this kind of
genetic tool can be developed or it
existed previously so CRISPR allows us
to perform targeted alteration into the
genome and genome is a collection of all
the genes present in a cell at a
particular point of time but how does
this can be achieved
so CRISPR stands for clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats a
mouthful term right so CRISPR is
actually a sequence information which is
present in our in bacterial genome and
it is regularly interspersed and
repetitive in nature that's why it's
called palindromic repeats and there is
a protein which is associated with
CRISPR locus which is known as CRISPR
associated protein line which works like
a molecular Caesar we're going to talk
about this mechanism in a moment but
CRISPR can be understood as a defense
mechanism against viruses that are equal
I use against page viruses so the phrase
viruses are the key enemies of e.coli
which infect them and kill them
so virus has developed a defense
mechanism which is embedded in their
genome and which is in terms of a DNA
sequence CRISPR locus and a caste gene
which is producing a protein caste 9 now
the sequence information of the CRISPR
locus is strikingly similar to the
sequence information present in the fat
genome scientists scratch their head why
this sequence informations are identical
and similar what is the consequence of
that or what is the cause of that one
hypothesis is when the fudge infected
the bacteria and the fed genetic
material is
inside the bacteria and try to get
integrated into the bacterial genome
these sequences remain incorporated in
the CRISPR locus now once the sequence
get incorporated into the CRISPR locus
they become a part of the bacterial
genome and let's say there is a second
infection by the same patch
now this CRISPR locus would create
specific RNA which is targeting the
phage genome and the caste gene product
which is caste 9 would get associated
with that RNA which is produced by the
CRISPR Lucas called guide RNA and
another RNA called tracer RNA and
ultimately this caste 9 along with this
tracer and guide RNA would cleave the
fudge genome now once the fat genome is
cleaved using this CRISPR caste 9 system
the fudge DNA would be degraded and that
is how the bacteria protects itself from
phage viruses and that's that's how it
works it's a bacterial adaptive immune
system so precise and beautiful
scientists learned about this thing it's
a definitely interesting phenomena but
how does scientists figure out they can
use this system to manipulate our own
genome a system which is presenting
bacteria and they use it for their own
immune response scientists can now
manipulate that and try to use it for
gene manipulation so scientists at early
21st century took biochemist approach
which is fairly simple
they know this CRISPR caste 9 can cleave
a particular region of DNA in a
sequence-specific manner so they can in
a test tube they can put DNA they can
put the guide RNA tracer RNA and the
caste 9 and expect that it would cleave
it and definitely they can understand
the result by running it into the
agarose gel electrophoresis very simple
and
they can see if the cast nine has done
its job then they would obtain cleaved
bands of different sizes smaller than
the unclipped one now this is pretty
interesting now scientists ask the
question that can we use different
different guide RNA to target this
system into a specific region if it is
true then in the agarose gel
electrophoresis depending upon which
type of kyra RNA or which combination of
guide RNA we are using we're going to
get different band sizes and that's what
scientists observed depending upon which
type of guide RNA we are using they're
able to obtain different size and
different lengths of the pans that means
changing the guide RNA sequence they can
really target this cleaving mechanism
and that was the turning point and that
told scientists that really we can use
this system to manipulate any genome of
our interest provided we know the
sequence information and can target our
cleaving machinery to that particular
location it's like a very targeted at
very much targeted attack now CRISPR can
be performed on many cell types
including human cells and human stem
cells so let's look at it so this is a
human stem cell and if you target one
particular genomic locus with CRISPR and
try to cut it what happens is inside our
cell there are repairing mechanism which
would try to repair the cut or repair
the damage such that we can have a
genomic integrity right and there are
the mechanisms that are followed in the
eukaryotic cells are non-homologous end
joining or homology dependent repair but
here is a trick that we can play let's
say we have targeted our CRISPR
machinery to a particular genomic locus
where we want to make a cut and it has
produced a double strand break and we
want to create a point mutation now when
this double-stranded break would be
prepared by homologous dependent
recombination then we provide our repair
illegal which would be incorporated
in that broken strand and this repair
oligo contains one mutation and now the
repaired strand by our own repair
machinery which would incorporate a
mutated version and that's how we can
incorporate point mutations not only
that this point mutations could lead to
dramatic changes and many of the disease
associated point mutations can be
studied using these approach also the
double-stranded break can be repaired by
a donor plasmid containing our sequence
let's say GFP or let's say our reporter
gene that is how we can create a knock
in line or knock in reporter as if we're
genetically tagging that gene or the
gene product been enabled and that is
how we can perform knock ins not only
these things CRISPR can be used for
diverse of functions like for example
CRISPR can be used for genetic
manipulation creating knockouts knock
aims point mutations etc CRISPR can be
used to label genomic locus so there is
a emerging field known as CRISPR fish or
CRISPR mediated fluorescence in situ
hybridization you can understand the
CRISPR is a targeting mechanism by which
we can target a specific genomic locus
and then if you instead of cutting it
you can tag it with a fluorophore then
we can identify that not only that
CRISPR can be used to manipulate
transcription as well using specific
CRISPR driven constructs we can activate
or inactivate a gene of interest in a
spatiotemporal manner
now the futuristic goal is to make gene
therapy using CRISPR based approaches
now that is it for this particular video
but in subsequent video I'll be talking
about the use of CRISPR how CRISPR was
developed and how we can perform CRISPR
in human cell lines so for now if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you and stay tuned to the next
video
you